hi skipper well
careful real skipper's right behind you
he's looking right at me
so much better it's so good look you're
kind of dressed the same it's like
well i woke up at four o'clock this
morning and started doing push-ups just
like i could be the second hardest
working person on the red carpet tonight
you see you see guys time were you up
doing your push-ups what time
um i don't sleep so i was already out
yes
that's why you look rough anyway keep
going wow okay
we need a makeup jack on emily guys
she's looking shiny
guys wow we are at the happiest place on
earth
are you remember that let's remember
that let's kind of just okay
remember build each other up okay we are
let's build
here i am wait speaking of building each
other up is it true that you
ghosted dwayne when he first pitched you
on this project honestly it wasn't
intentionally hurtful it was just
because i hadn't read the script yet he
sent a very nice video
and i hadn't read the script so i didn't
respond until i'd read the script and
when i read the script
i know i know he hates the story well
because that's
way out of it the thing about it is when
you send somebody a video like that and
i took my time in consideration and i
went all out i was like listen you're
the only one for this movie
and i mean that with all sincerity and i
need you to do this movie and we're
going to deliver the script for you
usually one would what's that thing oh
respond
right one would respond
and i told my director and my director
showed her and i was like what come on
what's up this is [ __ ]
yeah and it worked but it worked great
what was the deciding factor
how did he convince you in that video
what was the yes i saw my sexist man a
live cover
no i didn't that was by the way it was
years ago
it was years ago yeah i never give it up
and it never mentions it ever what was
the deciding factor that's important for
people to know it was the script
and actually not that you weren't
persuasive i was about to say drama
not that you weren't persuaded you were
incredibly charming and i loved your
video
but when i read the script i was
transported and kidnapped into this
beautiful world and then when jama
colette sarah our
incredible director said to me he goes
you know he's it's about love
i was like i'm in yeah yeah that's it
listen it's about love i was in
you see that i had to put up with no i'm
not allowed to say yes for years for
years now yes
three years promise i'm gonna let you
walk away in one second tell me real
quick
what can we look forward to seeing you
back in the wwe is there is there
anything you can tease about that for us
i love it breaking news congrats guys
thank you man nice hat
i love it i like it at the angle like
that it's good well thank you
stop learning get going don't stop don't
stop